asamoah le dixième maire du lamentin
il a succédé à georges graciant 1989
l'héritage de java serait dur à gérer
si on n'avait pas mis en place une bonne
équipe et d'ailleurs c'est la continuité
de l'équipe de jeunes gratien pour
digérer la menthe r je me suis dit tu à
l'irresponsabilité il faut que je sois à
la hauteur et compte tenu de mes lacunes
je ne suis pas un intellectuel vous lis
je suis un bâtisseur poser le brut comme
lui à l'époque et ça ne m'a jamais gêné
mais quand tu as ces responsabilités là
faut-il que tout un tas de gens de
qualité tu fais un choix d'hommes et de
femmes qui puisse travailler avec toi
est en congé s'il faut à cette époque en
public les relations avec
l'intelligencia communistes semblent
être au beau fixe dans les coulisses
c'est une autre affaire des tensions
existent entre la tête du pcm et le
maire du lamentin
jusqu'ici je suis profondément
communiste
mais à partir du moment que vous êtes
dans un ensemble au bout tel que ce que
vous lisez vous des enfantillages en
vous balance comme ça un certain moment
je ne fais pas partie des moutons de
panurge
en fait vous avez senti du profond mais
dans cette baie ses avocats me david
moyes vis-à-vis de moi je n'ai jamais
été pris au sérieux
1992 un communiste devient président de
la région martinique et 1004 gras est
élu au bénéfice de l'âge
grâce à pierre petit c'était un ami mais
une fois qu'il a été élu au niveau de
l'art du conseil
régional de l'époque il est devenu le
jouet desserte 1995 l'univers de pierre
samot s'effondre il sera placé 33 jours
en détention provisoire
c'est quelque chose que l'on n'oublie
pas mais je n'ai pas fait une affaire
parce que je ne suis nullement inquiétés
parce que j'ai découvert qu'il y avait
une passion particulière
j'avais découvert un certain nombre de
choses que je ne pouvais accepter est la
meilleure façon de m'éliminer
c'est tellement péché de me représenter
pour un deuxième mandat
les maires d'une amante et miel examen
pour favoritisme trafic d'influencé
corruption a été placé sous mandat de
dépôt à la prison de fort de france
on me met des menottes au momen au
palais de justice
des milliers de l'amandinois se sont
déplacés ils ont ébranlé les numides à
lévis moi je rigole je plaisante
non non non non
s'il ya une humiliation si tu veux
fautif quelque part si tu subi les
conséquences
tu me lis alors qu'il est en pleine
tempête judiciaire birsa mot est
brillamment réélu pour un deuxième
mandat à la mairie du lamentin
c'est une revanche et votre maire pierre
samot 84 avec els 66 % soit 7600 par un
terroir ça à effacer tout pouvoir les
péripéties extra je ne suis pas le mac à
chameau fonctions ça tout effacer et je
suis devenu l'homme qui agite toujours
voulu être est un démocrate respectueux
et des événements respectueux de l'autre
dans sa carrière politique bien sa mort
a aussi été du député en 2002 avant que
son élection ne soient invalidés l'année
d'après il aura aussi été président de
la casser
[Applaudissements]